welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for a presentation titled
towards antibody based treatment of
covid19
a panel of human neutralizing monoclonal
antibodies targeting
stars kov2 spike at multiple epitopes
it's my pleasure to introduce to you dr
mazor
who is the head of the department of
infectious diseases
at the israel institute and
he earned his doctorate from the
weizmann institute
for science at riva haute israel where
he conducted his
thesis study on developing
photodynamic-based drugs
for cancer therapy for complete
biography of our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation
we want to encourage you to submit them
to the q
a box and our speaker will address those
questions
following his presentation and as a
reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits
click on that continuing education
credits tab
located on the top right corner of your
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits please join me now in welcoming
our presenter
dr ohad mazur i will now turn the
presentation
over to him welcome sir
hi so today i will tell you about our
efforts
to develop antibody-based treatment for
covet 19.
first of all just let me tell you who we
are
so iabr is a governmental
cutting edge a resource facility
institute
that specialized in the fields of
biology chemistry
and environmental sciences and
we have national and international
collaborations in the biology
unit division we focus on studies
of different bacteria toxins and viruses
so let's go into antibodies
so we wish to to have
to let the evolution do its best
to to make the best antibodies
in the way that the evolution do it is
by
affinity motivation in vivo so it starts
with a vdj general combination
and then upon exposure to an antigen
there is a somatic hypermutation
and mostly in hot spots across the
cdrs region the parts of the antibody
that binds the antigen and
the resulting antibodies have improved
affinity
and upon the second or third exposure to
the same antigen
these whole cycles go on and on until
a very high affinity antibodies are
reached um
mainly in the uh reaching
stealing affinity of the of the in the
nanowire
range so in our group
we isolate hyafini antibodies that
enable specific neutralization
and successive detection of target
antigens
mostly toxins viral cells and bacteria
and our methodology is to obtain
peripheral subcultural lymphocytes
from human patients or from immunized
animals
and then we isolate hyaphine antibodies
using fresh display
libraries we generate a
full-length antibodies and characterize
them
just a quick overview of our methodology
so this is the antibody we are talking
about the viability
a that is expressed as a single chain
both the vehicle and the vehicle aspects
of the sync engine
and a antibody on the surface of a
filamentous
phage the enthalpy in phage we create
a library that contains hundreds of
million different phages or different
antibodies and then by process
termed panning we select
only these antibodies that specifically
bind the antigen this process can be
repeated several times
in order to enrich
and specifically isolate the desired
antibodies
the way to develop a or to create
such a good library is to amplify
the genes that encodes to the whole
variety of antibodies from the donor
both to the heavy chain a viable
religion and to the light and viable
legends we are talking about
both the lambta and the kappa in order
to do this
we have a specific and very
um large repertoire of primers for each
specie we then
assemble them randomly together to
create
two libraries one for the heavy train
with the lambda
a trains and the second for the copper
chains
and then we sequence many clones
of each library in order to ensure that
it is
a a diverse we we're using
the sanger sequencing stack studio
um system and just for example after a
second round of planning
we we test a random
um clones from the library and as you
can see
there are several clones in each library
that bind
to the antigen and after the third round
most of the clones usually bind the
antigen
some of them with a very high affinity
we then reformat the antibodies for
to a full length a igg so
this is the an antibody so we are using
for all our antibodies a constant
region a human fc igg one
type a region
to which we join the viable regions that
were derived from the
phase display library at the end of the
planning process
we then expressed these antibodies intro
or in heck two nine three cells here we
find them in
further characterize basically
in our laboratory we are focusing on
a on by pathogens
that are a biplate associated
but in the last few months we have
isolated a panel of human antibodies
that we hope will serve as the basis for
combined post-exposure therapy for scope
to
infection so star scope 2 this is the
virus you are
all well familiar with this we are
specifically want to target the spikes
and what we aim to do is to
isolate antibodies that target different
epitopes
on the spike protein so
we obtained the lymphocytes from a
recovered
impatience we also obtained from a
humanized animals but today i will
focus on our human
antibodies we created the library
and now we are characterizing using the
antibodies
so we have found the rivalry using
the receptor binding domain this is the
the moiety
of the spikes that specifically bind
the human h2 receptor
and we cloned the the resulted
we sequenced the resulted clones uh
reformatted them into a igg
and by the end of this project we ended
up
with eight different antibodies that
belong
to a different germ lines both for the
heavy
and for the lychees
this antibodies specifically bind
to the receptor binding domain which is
part of the
s1 uh region of the spike
as you can see it does not by that they
are
not binding the antenna domain for
example
we then wanted to measure
their affinity so we are using octet
it's a bio-layer
interferometry system the antibody in
question
is immobilized to the sensor
and then we add the the
the antigen in this case rbd a different
concentration
and we measure both the k on and the k
off
part and and then we can calculate for
each antibody
the the the the affinity the the kd
and as can be seen here all our
antibodies
have a quite good affinity which is in
the lower
and even sub and anamola range
we also asked whether our antibodies can
bind
the antigens simultaneously or in other
words
whether they bind to different epitopes
so we again are using the octet system
so the first antibody in question for
example fd65
is immobilized on the sensor and then we
add
the the antigen in this case the s1
and as you can see upon binding of the
s1 there is a very nice
a shift of indicating for
the binding to the antibody and then we
wash the
the axis and then we add another
antibody
so if the second antibody binds to
different
epitope on the antigen then it will
result
in another wavelength shift as shown
here
if it's bind to the same epitope
then we will have no a further a
shift so we characterized
all the antibodies and
we could classify them into four
groups two of the groups
only are represented only by one
antibody
and two groups have three antibodies
and basically what we are
seeing here is that the the small
moiety the receptor binding domain
contains
at least four different epitopes
we then asked whether those antibodies
can neutralize
the the virus we are using in vitro
system
to test the neutralization uh on a
on a various cells and as can be seen
here basically
seven out of the eight antibodies
can can neutralize the virus we have
also
added here a control antibody the rb18
and isotype control
and just want you to focus on our best
uh neutralization a neutralizing
antibody
md65 which belongs to the second group
and also you can see that the antibody
62 from group 3
is also a a very
high neutralization potency
we then ask whether we can say something
about
the mechanism of the neutralization of
these antibodies
again using the octet so the first
antibody
is immobilized the sensor and then we
add
the receptor binding domain and then we
add
the receptor a recombinant receptor
in human a2 and we test
when we test whether this receptor can
bind
to the rbd in the presence of the
neutralizing antibody
so we took a represent a representative
antibody from each group
and as can clearly be seen here
is that for example antibody 29 belongs
to group
1 does not inhibit
the binding of the receptor to the rbd
and so does antibody 47
while two of our best neutralizing
antibodies
antibodies 65 and antibody 62
completely abolished the ability of the
receptor to bind to the ability
so this can tell us about
the most important maybe most important
part
of the bi of the of the neutralization a
mechanism needed for a star scope too i
will
please bear in mind that antibodies
47 and 29 both
inhibit the activity of the virus in
vitro
so i guess maybe
probably to other important
mechanisms
so where we are now so we are continuing
to characterize the activity of the
antibodies
in vivo in animal models we also
perform clinical evaluations both
pharmacokinetics
toxicity etc we are currently also
characterize another set of human
antibodies
and antibodies that have been derived
from a
saskov to immunize the animals
and with that i would like to thank the
people in my group
and all the other people who helped us
to the anti-activated engineering
group and to our colleagues from their
biology unit
and thank you all for listening
thank you dr mazur for that outstanding
presentation
and we will now move to the live q a
portion of the presentation
and as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box
so dr mazzar we have already some
existing questions coming in
our first question from our audience
member is
have you tested your antibody panel
against
any of the stars or mers viruses and if
so
what type of inhibition did you observe
hi susie thank you so unfortunately
we did not test our antibodies
for against the other stars or earth
viruses
i if there is there will be
a cross centralization i guess will be
with the south
which shares a high homology with the
source of two virus but i don't know
about the
the nerves i guess for the best it
probably will not work
as well thank you so much and
i want to thank our audience members for
coming today and remind them that any
questions not
answered today will be answered via
email
dr mizora based on your data
do you think that when this gets used in
clinical trials
you would need to to do like a
combination of antibodies
how would you determine which set of
antibodies to include
well that's a very good question
basically
once we have several antibodies against
several epitopes we can combine them
whether this will be the best way to
start i don't know i guess
we will wish to start with one antibody
preferably the
the best one i guess mv65
and then
we'll see what happens but if we have to
combine them
i guess we will take the most
neutralizing antibody which is a
nd 65 and nd 62 which can
also bind simultaneously to the virus
so they can act together whether
synergistically or just
as a combination but i guess this will
be my
my two best candidates for combination
therapy
thank you so much i mean we have one
more question coming in
live can you talk a little bit more
about the next steps
in which could be a normal or expected
timeline
in the pre-clinical and clinical steps
yes so basically the clinical
steps will include first of all
toxicity studies and pharmacokinetics
in different animals and what we are
doing
also right now is to try our antibodies
in vivo
we have a mouse model
the transgenic human race to
a mice model that we are currently
trying to see whether our antibodies can
provide therapy for a copied infection
cognitive infection of these animals
so this is what where we are now and we
hope to
establish the clinical steps
in a few months and go to directly
thank you so much and dr majora thank
you for your time today for your
presentation
and also for your important research and
i want to thank our audience members for
their outstanding questions
dr mazur will be moving into the expert
lounge right after this talk to continue
discussing his presentation
and answering questions submitted during
the presentation
and this presentation will be available
on demand
viewing through 12 months from today
so all the way up to next year 2021
in october and please share it with your
colleague who may have be
interested in today's topic thank you
again for your participation
and see you in that expert lounge take
care everyone
go bye and stay healthy thank you dr
missouri
thank you bye